welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of what if
episode 1 which ponders the question
what if peggy carter became a super
soldier instead of steve rogers but also
what if steve rogers became the first
iron man what if nick fury and hawkeye
had to clean squid chunks out of the
project pegasus basement and what if
jeffrey wright was watching you from
space right now you'd prefer that
wouldn't you i was honestly pretty
surprised how many mcu connections in
mythology they were able to work into
this show so i'm gonna break down all
the easter eggs and subtle animation
details that you might have missed and
some theories for how this really could
tie into the live action mcu as the
show's creators have indicated marvel
studios plans to do this video is
sponsored by our friends at heroes
journal more on them later we open on
the marvel studios title which shifts
into animated brush strokes as a way of
signaling to us that we are still in the
marvel cinematic universe of the films
with the voices of mostly the same
actors or actors trying to emulate them
just one that visually appears in a
different medium similar to how animated
star wars series are every bit as canon
as the films in the mandalorian are the
voice of jeffrey wright as uwatu the
watcher guides us through the opening
titles
time
space
reality
it's more than a linear path time space
and reality are all abstract concepts
with infinity stone counterparts and may
be also a clue for the universal
constants that this series will treat as
variables instead placing characters in
variable times variable points in space
variable realities now the watchers are
marvel cosmic entities who observe and
record history throughout the multiverse
watch the watcher is assigned to our
universe which is why uatu is the one
narrating to us right now watchers
actually made live-action cameos in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. they were
stuck listening to stan lee's stories
which was a nod to the fan theory that
stan lee's various mcu cameos could have
made him uwatu really stan lee was
probably closer to entities like the one
above all which was an unseen meta
figure that was likened to artist jack
kirby but huanche's appearance here is a
red outlined silhouette in space not the
flesh-colored heads of the comics he
actually looks more like the marvel
entity known as eternity which was the
living embodiment of the universe itself
a shattered prism shows moments from the
upcoming season and one of those moments
captain carter itself contains infinite
variables within reflecting how this one
altered choice by peggy carter also
leads to several other variances that we
see in this episode and can imagine
beyond this episode's ending then we
open on the events of the first cap film
which was itself visually stylized with
desaturation to evoke a nostalgic
quality the animation on what if is
designed with the same idea in mind with
director brian andrews citing the work
of artist j.c liondecker from the 1920s
and 30s for simple but life-like 2d
characters and that warmness is
heightened in this opening scene with
this random bright beam of sunlight on
steve even though the scene that they
base it on was in a windowless dimly lit
lab but also during that opening
prologue we dissolve from cap's shield
to the planet of earth superimposing the
shield over the entire world the way
this shield metaphorically became a suit
of armor around the world hayley atwell
returns to voice peggy carter steve is
actually voiced by actor josh keaton who
sounds a hell of a lot like chris evans
does stanley tucci and dominic cooper
return as dr erskine and howard stark
and tommy lee jones character colonel
phillips appears but he doesn't speak
but then the key variant moment occurs
no i'd prefer to stay
there
that's the moment
that created a new universe now that was
a throwaway line in the original captain
america film adrian carter don't you
think it would be more comfortable in
the booth oh yes of course sorry but
whereas peggy watched from the
observation deck there here she stays
which also leads to everyone else who is
in that booth staying on the floor too
including the hydra assassin whose bomb
is now right beside erskine's foot
causing him to get killed in the blast
not be shot by him right after colonel
phillips also gets shot and killed along
with steve though he survives and peggy
shoots and kills the assassin right
there preventing the need for a street
chase that superpower with steve rogers
would have gone on but remember in that
movie peggy carter had that assassin
dead in her sights and she would have
killed him had steve not tackled her so
peggy steps into the chamber powering
herself up in a sequence matching the
storyboard of the film
[Applause]
[Music]
colonel flynn a new character voiced by
bradley whitford chews her out
afterwards every last drop of that dr
erskine serum went into you and if we
get lucky someday your blood might tell
us how to make a real super soldier yeah
look at those vials of blood they're
taking out by my count i see 19 of them
plus two more that they're doing just
seems like a whole bunch of loose ends
that could set up future government
experiments with peggy carter's blood
now in the live action mcu the attempts
to restart the super soldier experiment
included general ross turning bruce
banner into the hulk along with emil
blonsky into a super soldier who
eventually became abomination and
according to the fact of the winter
soldier there were similar experiments
going on linked with isaiah bradley but
in this case peggy carter's blood could
be the basis of characters like thaddeus
ross becoming red hulk maybe even bruce
banner's cousin jennifer walter is
becoming she-hulk then peggy boxes and
knocks the bag off the rigging just like
live action steve did when he was
restless and she kick flips a weight and
frisbees at end of the wall just like
the big kickflip move in captain america
winter soldier and she's just showing
that she is ready for the shield
meanwhile wounded steve does physical
therapy similar to roadie at the end of
civil war but like roadie steve has a
future in a stark design armored suit
then on to the turnsburg church which
actually opened the first captain
america film and compared to that
establishing shot now the church's front
light is not lit but still schmidt rolls
up in his roadster with the same
close-up of his modified ben's hood
ornament with the hydra logo now ross
marquan voices red skull he actually
took over the role from hugo weaving
when red skull returned an infinity war
the wooden engraving of the idroso
world's tree here is way bigger and
schmidt's hand runs across a new section
that was not in the film a ring with a
tesseract in the middle and tentacles
snaking out of course foreshadowing how
he will use the tesseract to open a
portal for the interdimensional champion
to arrive through but really all of this
is way of showing that here schmidt's
end goal for the tesseract is not world
domination under the hydra flag really
reaching out into the cosmos which is a
bit ironic because in the movie red
skull did end up blasted out in the
space but here he ends up dead on earth
peggy howard and colonel flynn review
the tesseract in a textbook and above
that illustration are some norse runes
that's what's the case with loki
marvel's norse alphabet is all over the
place because this seems to translate to
gibberish but the caption beneath is
italian that translates to the hypercube
in the true shape of the space stone
whoa the fact that the tesseract
contained an infinity stone did not seem
to be public knowledge though who knows
this textbook could contain some
references or citations from the italian
book of cagliostro which contain
knowledge about the time stone and
ivagimoto so i don't know maybe infinity
stones were some ancient knowledge on
earth just known by certain people
howard gives her her new suit in a box
labeled howard's designer clothing and
also her own shield which instead of the
stars and stripes now bears iconography
of the union jack and notice how there's
a blue stripe on the outer edge instead
of the red one on cap shield now the
heroes journal is here to help you
accomplish your goals by turning them
into a quest based on goal setting
psychology and the story theory behind
some of your favorite fandoms the heroes
journal helps you discover the story you
tell about yourself and define the quest
you want to undertake they actually just
released their latest journal the
astoria magic academy the new feature of
this model is that the art changes every
single day there is a visual story that
unfolds every single day throughout the
journal
with chapter reflection pages every
seven daily pages so like as you fill
out every page you can just see how your
story is evolving it's really cool but
whether your goals involve improving
your health or taking a step forward in
your career or finally undertaking that
big creative project the hero's journal
guides you along the journey to
achieving your goal what's really cool
about the heroes journal is that it
builds a positive narrative about
productivity versus a shame-based
narrative you get to feel good about all
those tiny steps you're taking on a
daily basis the hero's journal is
available for purchase now just head to
heroesjournal.co
or click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars for your 10
off so carter suits up and stops arnhem
zola at berlin's brandenburg gate and we
hear her theme music
[Music]
which is a slightly altered version of
the captain america theme
[Music]
and again i really like how they use
lighting in this case to give dimension
to these otherwise 2d characters to make
their movements look more fluid and pop
off the screen like notice that whenever
carter makes a power move she's always
illuminated by one of the headlights of
one of the cars she's stopping or has
just flipped over the end result is to
outline her in this white glow and also
creating a really nice glare off her
shield carter walks away from this with
the tesseract and howard uses it to
power the hydra stomper armor for steve
i'm not sure why it would have to be
steve who gets to pilot it i don't know
having a tiny test pilot would be useful
to lighten the overall load now in the
film howard does experiment briefly on
the tesseract for weapons purposes but
while this episode doesn't really go
into it it is hugely significant for
howard to build a flying suit of armor
essentially an iron man mark 1 prototype
decades before his son would do so
carter rescues the 107th approaching on
a motorcycle placing her shield in front
of her just like how steve does in the
other scene in the movie and inside we
meet the howling commandos including dum
dum duggan actually neil mcdonough
returns to voice in here there's also
james montgomery fallsworth gabe jones
jacques daniele jim morita and bucky
barnes sebastian stan voices a few
one-liners in this episode that uh well
reminded me that i'm an adult watching a
kid's show there's the famous door
opening shot from the film and steve
drops in with the hydra stomper actually
i love how inside his face appears
surrounded by a heads up display similar
to the close-ups of tony stark inside
the iron man helmet but instead of the
digital projections they're all analog
dials and meters he zaps a tank and it
blows up but for one frame the blast
recolors a shot in all white and then
all black just a cool way of showing the
brightness of the explosion that is
powered by infinity stone steve says
let's hear it for captain carter which
bucky said for steve in the movie let's
hear it for captain america
and then during a swing music montage
there's a fun tracking shot that follows
carter all the way from outside through
the cockpit of a german plane not
cutting as she fights her way through
the cabin then up through the hatch and
then down the tail some fun storyboarded
action here a nazi general snaps at red
skull captain carter and this so-called
hydro stomper are wreaking havoc this is
actually a vocal cameo by snl actor
turned snl announcer daryl hammond
carter and rogers share a drink i miss a
good whiskey
but the serum doesn't allow me to feel
the effects kind of a reversal of the
scene in the film i can't get drunk
did you know that
your metabolism burns four times faster
than the average person then they staged
this train mission just like the one of
the film but carter calls it here
operation wear eagles dare a reference
to the 1968 world war ii film that was
also set in the alps and bucky almost
falls as he does in the live-action
version but carter saves him
thanks you almost ripped my arm off yeah
we we get it bucky you lose your arm but
in this case it is steve who dies
seemingly but actually falls into
hydra's clutches carter comes back and
interrogates zola with toby jones
returning to voice the character i will
tell you nothing
he told me everything and carter points
to castle crake on the map a name
evoking the word kraken which is the sea
monster of legend with similar giant
tentacles as the interdimensional beasts
that they end up facing there's another
long warner that follows carter running
through the black forest over the castle
walls taking down the guards and then
opening the gate for the others to come
through red skull uses a tesseract to
open a portal decades before shields
project pegasus would use it the same
way this tentacled creature with a mouth
full of sharp teeth is never named i
guess it's similar to the
interdimensional beast called the
abelisk in guardians vol 2 but i'm
thinking it could be one of the elder
gods or many angled ones from the
2009-2010 realm of king's marvel comics
a future quasar the guardians of the
galaxy nova project pegasus versus the
revengers the many angled ones are
lovecraftian interdimensional beings
that look a lot like this one of them is
schuma gorath who's actually rumored to
appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness see i know this
multiverse stuff is getting harder and
harder to understand but so far in the
marvel multiverse it seems like you have
timelines and universes which are
realities parallel to our own that
sometimes branch off from each other to
form new ones as we saw in loki but then
in between those timelines you have what
marvel seems to be calling dimensions in
realms that they say are beyond space
and time and these are the surreal acid
trips that we see like in the doctor
strange movies the dark dimension also
the quantum realm and i think in a
dimension like this is where the many
angled ones reside that could explain
how peggy carter ended up going through
that dimension to end up in the present
day much like scott lang's quantum realm
time dilation and avengers end game now
howard cannot read the german controls
but they translate to voltage resistance
capacity charge close load reduction
power supply override and hydropower
actually when he cranks up that closed
lever that is when the portal begins to
close he actually mentioned spending a
weekend with hedy lamarr who is an
austrian-born american actress who's
actually a major asset to the allied war
effort she co-invented the radio
guidance system that was intended for
torpedoes and she got a ton of warbond
sold so yeah someone you could imagine
howard stark bragging about hanging out
with carter picks up a sword and with
her shield she just looks very much like
an english knight now there is a captain
britain in the marvel comics brian
braddock who leads the interdimensional
captain britain core and peggy actually
mentioned braddock in an off-screen line
and end game if we're talking about
futures for captain carter i would love
to see her organize the captain britain
core rogers and carter's raincheck dance
date from the movie comes back here
except carter is the one sacrificing
herself except she doesn't die or go
into ice she immediately transports into
the future the portal opened by the
tesseract in the project pegasus
basement and what looks like the days
before loki's arrival via that same
portal in avengers samuel l jackson
jeremy renner returned to voice nick
fury and clint barton and carter says we
won the war which is a bit of irony
considering she has arrived just in time
to help the avengers fight loki's
invasion her war is really just
beginning now again the producers plan
to make captain carter a returning hero
in this series she's confirmed to be in
an episode for season two and trailer
footage shows her talking to doctor
strange in a different episode maybe
from this season and firstly i would
love to see a cameo of her in live
action like drifting in the background
of the multiverse of madness fighting
that tentacled beast like gandalf
fighting the balrog but that that might
just be me let me know your thoughts
down below and you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you